[Music]
hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain a drama film called the man who
sold his skin spoilers ahead watch out
and take care
the protagonist sam lives with a friend
in a small apartment in lebanon he
frequently stares at the pictures of his
married ex-girlfriend abeer still
confident that he will get back together
with her someday he and his roommate
work on a poultry farm and make enough
to eat two meals a day on special
occasions they crash art exhibitions and
steal the food presented to the guests
in one of such exhibitions the
receptionist suspects them and asks for
their names right then the manager of
the gallery soraya starts talking to the
receptionist and sam gets a chance to
walk away seconds later soraya asks him
his name and finds out that he is not on
the guest list upon discovering that he
is here for the food she asks him to
wait till the end and take the leftovers
home sam is surprised by the lady's
kindness but he feels embarrassed to
accept the food it just doesn't taste as
good when you don't steal it then we are
introduced to a controversial
contemporary artist named jeffrey he is
known for his outrageous way of
representing social norms in the form of
art he is also the most valuable artist
of the modern day as every single one of
his creations sells for more than a
million dollars upon finding out that
sam is a freeloader and a syrian refugee
jeffrey takes interest in him he brings
sam to a bar for a drink and reveals
that he wants to create art about
refugees and their struggles to get a
visa he also finds out about sam's wish
to go to belgium where his ex-girlfriend
abeer has moved in with her husband
using his desperation jeffrey wants to
take advantage of the guy when sam
inquires what he wants jeffrey replies
that he wishes to have his back sam is
excited to return home the next day
because he has arranged a video call
with his ex-girlfriend they see each
other after a long time and feel the
love all over again abeer is looking for
a job as a translator and until then she
is working from home with her husband
the news saddens sam because that would
mean she and her husband are spending
more time together just then his husband
ziad comes into his view and kisses her
before she ends the call sam is left
disheartened after that he desperately
wants to go to belgium and the only way
to do so is by contacting jeffrey later
he goes to the art gallery and talks to
jeffrey's lawyer on the phone he
explains that if sam signs the contract
he will have to sell his skin for a lot
of money the rest of the conditions are
written on the contract itself without
thinking much of it sam signs the paper
unaware that the decision is about to
change his life in the following scene
jeffrey tattoos the picture of a
schengen visa on sam's back to represent
how toxic the world is for refugees like
him since a schengen visa is one of the
hardest to get it makes the tattoo more
meaningful jeffrey calls it a living art
one that crosses all lines like the
revolution has crossed all lines in the
current world in the evening sam returns
home with a real passport and visa
jeffrey has provided it to him so he can
be taken around europe for exhibition
the following day soraya and sam are on
a plane flying to belgium sam couldn't
be happier to finally meet a beer he
reaches a hotel in belgium and tries
calling her but gets no reply after many
attempts she calls him back and is
visibly in a bad mood he says he wants
to meet her but the conversation is
interrupted by her husband he invites
sam to their house and doesn't forget to
mention that he and his wife will
welcome them sam hardly gets to talk to
abeer before the call ends abruptly
following that a photo shoot takes place
which is way out of sam's comfort zone
he tries making conversations with the
photographer but it only ends up making
the interaction more awkward after the
shoot soraya gives sam her phone so he
can take a picture of himself and send
it to his mother who is worried about
him in the next few days his back tattoo
shakes the entire world and becomes a
controversial sensation he sees the
tattoo's picture on every billboard in
every corner of the city he is also made
to stay still for hours in art
exhibitions where he is the main
attraction if he moves even to talk to
fans the organizers order him to sit
back down it is almost as if sam no
longer owns his body sam reminisces
about the life he lived one year ago in
raqqa he lives amidst the syrian civil
war but the presence of his girlfriend a
beer makes everything better one
afternoon they meet on a bus where sam
finds out a beer is going on a date with
a different man that evening however
abeer has only agreed to meet him for
her mother's sake and has no intention
of marrying him sam jokingly asks her to
marry him and inquires if there is a
priest on the bus a man laughs and
starts singing a song while everyone
dances to it in the following scene sam
is home when a bunch of policemen knock
on his door and arrest him they believe
that he is a revolutionary because he
mentioned the word freedom when they
were on the bus earlier a police
inspector asks him about his true
intentions and secretly tells him to run
away the policeman is a friend of sam's
father and knows that he is not a threat
but if he is convicted he will surely be
hanged to death hence when no one is
around sam jumps out of the window and
runs to meet a beer i run to meet a beer
all the time at her home a man has come
with his family to arrange a wedding a
beer sees sam and runs to him excitedly
but she soon finds out he cannot stay
there for long in fact he will now have
to run away from syria if he wants to
live because the government has declared
him a terrorist in an attempt to save
him abeer calls the guy who wishes to
marry her his name is ziad and he works
in the syrian embassy abeer introduces
sam as her classmate and asks ziad if he
can do anything to help him clear his
name ziad doesn't believe them when they
claim that sam hasn't done anything
wrong with no way out he has to say
goodbye to a beer and run away in the
following scene sam's sister is driving
to lebanon she is stopped at the
checkpoint where the guards make sure
she isn't carrying anything or anyone
illegal when they find nothing she is
let into the country sam comes out from
under the seat revealing that he was
hidden the entire time he is finally
safe but is now a refugee in a new
country without the love of his life
back in the present he is resting in his
expensive hotel room when a man knocks
on his door he is a representative of
syria and has been sent by the
government authorities they are planning
to sue jeffrey for abusing sam and using
his body for art hence they need his
help in doing so however sam slams the
door on the man's face enraged that the
same government that wanted him dead is
now asking for his help when it gets
dark he calls his mother who is worried
about him all her relatives have painted
sam as a freak who sold his body for
money he makes her understand that
they're just jealous because he reached
the height of success they were never
able to achieve the next day sam finds
out a beer's address and goes to meet
her she sees him outside the house and
freezes in shock he lies that he works a
normal job in an art gallery which is
how he was able to fly to belgium the
lovers hug each other unaware that
abeer's husband ziad is watching them
sam understands that she cannot come
with him but he promises to always be
there for her in the following scene
ziad brings a beer to the art exhibition
to show her that sam lied to her about
his job on discovering the truth she is
horrified and worried for him ziad
insults sam which results in an
altercation in a fit of rage ziad hits
an expensive painting and damages it he
is arrested for it while jeffrey's
lawyer helps sam get out of this
situation at night a beer visits sam's
hotel room and talks to him about the
incident of the day she gets a call from
ziad and we find out he forcefully sent
her so she can persuade sam to not sue
him when sam finds out he says that
making legal decisions is not up to him
but the next day he declares that if
they do not let ziad go he will join
hands with the syrian government and
help them sue jeffrey for violating his
human rights as a result they
reluctantly have to let ziad free sam no
longer wants to be an asset to jeffrey
he tries running away by saying that his
mother is ill but soraya knows he is
just bluffing he is again taken to the
exhibitions and placed in front of
everyone as an object jeffrey notices
that sam has grown a pimple on his back
and freaks out he compares it to his art
being mishandled and brings sam to the
hospital to get it treated at night
abeer calls sam and asks him how he's
doing sam on the other hand knows that
he is only hurting her by tagging her
love along with him hence he lies that
he has fallen in love with soraya and
ends the call after that he gets on a
call with his family who are happy that
he sent the money his sister and her
husband are starting a business and the
family finally has enough food for
everyone however sam then notices that
both of his mother's legs are amputated
she discloses that a wall fell on her
legs in an explosion a while ago sam
starts sobbing when he registers how
selfish he has been he called his mother
often but only to talk about his life he
regrets never asking her about herself
and wants to return home at this point
the following day sam finds out that a
wealthy broker has bought him at a
whopping 10 million euros when a
reporter asks them how they were able to
sell art that is attached to a human
soraya comes forward to answer she
discloses that laws related to human
trafficking applied to this case so they
had to trade in switzerland where they
could manipulate the translation and
make it legal the scene then cuts to
nine months later sam is in an auction
where people are bidding prices for him
suddenly something clicks inside his
head and he starts cursing everyone he
takes out an earphone which people think
is an explosive and they run away as he
laughs in the end he is imprisoned sam
has lost his mind tired of being treated
like a commodity when the lawyer comes
to bail him out he says he doesn't want
to go outside but upon seeing that a
beer is also with him he agrees to talk
abeer translates the lawyer's comments
to sam as an official translator she
also reveals that she has left her
husband and wants to be with him they
have spent too much time trying to mend
the situations they are in now it is
time for them to actually be together in
the following scene everyone is in the
court the lawyer is appealing for a bail
even though sam is against it but then
the judge shocks everyone by revealing
that sam's visa has expired so he has to
be transported back to syria no one can
do anything about it since it is a
requirement made by the law outside the
reporters inquire if sam is scared
because he is worth millions of dollars
but he says that he is happy to finally
go back home a few weeks later soraya
watches a video on her laptop sam has
been executed by syrian terrorists for
being a traitor not only that but the
group's skinned his back and sold the
tattoo on the black market it is somehow
found and shipped back to belgium in the
ending scene jeffrey watches two men
install the back tattoo to the wall at a
museum even after death sam doesn't stop
being an object then it is disclosed
that sam was never killed he is living
his best life with a beer in his village
the tattooed skin was fake and was
arranged by jeffrey who knew that he
couldn't hold sam for a life moreover
the tragedy of sam's alleged death makes
it more expensive in the last scene sam
and debeer are seen together enjoying
their freedom
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching